Uh, let's see.
Um, okay.
Why don't we go to our caller from the two,
four, eight area code?
Who's calling today from two, four, eight.
Does that mean?
Yeah, that's you.
Who's this?
Uh, this is Joseph from Michigan.
Hey Joseph, what's going on?
I just wanted to, to, to give a big thank
you, uh, because you, uh, you and Kyle Kalinsky,
uh, really helped pull me out of a really,
uh, really far right place, uh, that I had
been over the past few years.
How'd you get into that far right?
So, uh, my family's pretty liberal, so I was
just, you know, kind of like another color
called not too long ago.
I just kind of, you know, the, when I started
getting a holiday, cause I just automatically
assumed, oh, hey, I'm just going to be on
the left.
But, uh, what happened was I came across a
video from a youtube ring on his shoe on head
and uh, that was like, oh, you know, just
the person on the left criticizing people
on the left.
But then from her, I got to armored skeptic,
her, her boyfriend, now fiance, I think.
And from him, I got to Blair white and it
just kept going down this rabbit hole until
eventually I was watching a, until eventually
I was watching Stefan Molyneux and Lauren
southern and uh, and eventually, uh, I watched
it.
Eventually I watch a video by TJ Kirk or he
references, uh, Kyle Kalinsky.
So I went to watch him and in the recommended
of the videos, one from him, I've got a video
from you and I was asking you to for like
the past six months and you've really a do
program.
They pulled me out of the place I was at.
Well, listen, I appreciate that.
I also am a little concerned about one element
of this and this is a broader issue that goes
beyond not, not to pick on you, but let me
ask you this.
How long would you say the process was from
where you sort of got politically aware on
the left was pulled into the right and then
back to the left?
Like how long did that entire process take?
Uh, maybe four years.
Okay.
All right.
That, that's less concerning.
I, you know, sometimes when folks call in,
um, Joseph and they say a very similar story
to the one that you told, but they say it,
it happened within like a year or 10 months.
That's concerning to me because I'm worried
that people are so malleable that they can
so quickly be pulled into such extreme ideology
and then just by virtue of other videos that
they watch on youtube be pulled directly out
of it.
Like in an ideal world, it's so great that
you were pulled out of that.
Right.
And it's absolutely fantastic that that happened
and I'm really glad in an ideal world we would
be teaching critical thinking and philosophy
and civics starting at an early enough age
where one could not by virtue of stumbling
across some whack jobs on youtube, be pulled
into these outrageous beliefs to begin with.
You know what I mean?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It was a, it was a very slow process, like
as it was like first on the left curb, then
people on the left, then it was like, okay,
maybe centrism is cool and it's slowly okay,
maybe this rate ringer has a point.
Okay.
Maybe they have two points and then it just
slowly evolved from there.
What would you say was the most extreme belief
that you actually, uh, uh, sort of incorporated
into your set of beliefs?
Uh, the, the believe to ban all immigration
coming into the US.
That's interesting.
You know, a bunch of people that have called
in and said that they were pulled into the
right and then got out of it.
A lot of them say that they were pulled into
the right with immigration related, you know,
sort of pseudo nationalists, xenophobic phobic,
anti-immigrant stuff that, that is interesting.
I mean, it's anecdotal, it's just people who
call me, but that is notable that a bunch
of them mentioned that.
Oh yeah.
The, it's a big, the big thing, uh, getting
pulled in is the, is the immigration thing.
Yeah.
Joseph.
Listen, I'm glad you got out and uh, appreciate
you telling me your story.
Oh, thank you.
Thanks for taking my call.
Take care.
Appreciate it.
Joseph seemed to have a strange kind of like
delay going on with Joseph.
It was weird.
I don't know if that's in the system or that
was just the call with a call cold.
Joseph,